foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
week seven Sam week seven is here
how you feeling bro
I feel great man uh you know we're we're
still hitting our bets you know the
commenters I'm sure are ready to roast
me after the one and two start last week
finish four and two so I feel good about
that
um how you feeling man how are you
feeling
a slight Flex to start off the show I
like that I'm feeling good bro
we're going to get to it but you you
should know why I'm feeling good if my
49ers are playing today uh we're in
Vegas we're in Vegas we're going to the
game later let's bring on producer Ryan
producer Ryan welcome to the show I'm
looking at my phone guys and I'm looking
at a bunch of games it's it's a bunch of
good matchups today a bunch of good
matchups today
Ryan the Raiders game we're going seven
six and a half Sam you talk to me too uh
is that a lie six and a half I don't me
personally I'm not laying the points
with the Raiders I'll take the money
line and parlay it but the points stand
away ah it's too many points they're one
in four on on what Earth uh what planet
are the Raiders being seven point
favorite it's a good bet uh not this one
in fact even against the Texans even
against the Texans I can't stand away
from that
also also guys I see something very very
interesting the Jets taking on the
Broncos
the Jets they're always the lines like a
pick em when some places minus one and a
half
uh
something I don't know it's just
something about this game Sam it's a
backup quarterback in Denver
I'll save my take for for my six bets I
don't know if that was a really good
segue about you but uh but I will start
off you know what you you know how I do
it we're just going to kick the show off
we're going to kick we're going to go
right into this show producer Ryan we're
going to send you back to the chat thank
you for your thank you for your
contributions my brother but uh Sam
let's talk about it bro six Best Bets we
know why we're here the people know why
we're here we're here because you are
six Best Bets talk to us which way are
we leaning with the first one
yes we're starting off with the Banger
we are we are taking the Broncos we are
we're going against the Jets um I know
the public is all over all over the Jets
in this one but to me this is your like
ultimate sell High spot on the Jets at
the peak of their uh public perception
and buying it at the absolute lowest
point of the Broncos look I I know they
got a backup quarterback with Brett rip
it in there but that offense cannot be
any worse than it was with Russell
Wilson so what they're the 27th best
offense before now they're going to be
28th I don't care uh they're offense
stinks but I think what really matters
is their defense is absolutely
incredible second overall in team
defense and dvoa they're at home I trust
that defense against Zach Wilson at home
to to do some damage and
um and like I said I just I don't think
that Broncos offense can be really any
worse so I'm not too concerned about the
quarterback downgrade
um today
there it is fam that is your 45 seconds
you made a point that defense is really
really really they're real in Denver
they are real in Denver uh let's bring
back in producer Ryan because he's in
the chat
Ryan against the Japanese Sam Friedman
the people they said Sam Friedman wow
that's that's crazy Sam you have a good
week and then that's how they do you no
that's how that's how I'm doing him the
comments didn't say that I said that
the Jets are not good they clipped this
out after the show the Jets are not very
good the four and two jets are not good
that's a good take we gotta stop you
gotta stop looking at wins and losses to
decide who's good we're trying to
predict the future not look in the past
okay
um we have I want to win saying Sam is a
winning better uh we've got rsj Sam you
a goat uh OG one Jets and Giants both
are trap games so fading New York today
New York's been on a hot streak and now
we're fading them uh I was gonna say I
appreciate that I'm sure you're reading
like the two out of 50 comments so the
other 50 are like this guy sucks I hate
this guy so I appreciate it that's what
I always do yeah I always always got to
try and protect your ego man uh trigger
away say National tight end day Mark
Andrews and the Ravens to win and Travis
Kelsey and the Chiefs to win oh that's
juicy I love that we should have we
should pick it anytime TV for a tight
end
um maybe I'll change my pick
Sam knowing that it's National tight end
day you gave us your first pick
it's time for your second pick brother
which way are we leaning for the second
one all right my next pick I am taking
the Washington commanders plus five
points look I'll say this we are we are
six weeks in at this point we sort of
know who is good and who's not and it's
crazy to say but this Packers team is
just not good
um and it's not like a fluke either win
loss record they are 20th overall in
team Diva they are just not a very good
football team I know with the commanders
again you're you have Heineken there you
have a backup quarterback but heinecke
cannot be that much worse than Carson
Wentz so uh I I like the commanders
today their defense is very good I think
they can keep it close uh I thought the
Packers were going to be good this year
I thought missing Devonte Adams is not
gonna be a huge deal I was wrong they
miss them there's no chemistry with
receivers the o-line is a mess Rogers
don't look good I like Washington
there it is time Sam wow Sam's going
with the commanders plus five against
those Green Bay Packers Sam it might be
the day of the backup quarterback
because we got two backups quarterbacks
locked in ready to go uh that's two Sam
two picks we got four more you ready for
this next one
I am I'm just worried about my mic they
got me the professional setup like you
and it keeps falling out of my ear so
we're worried about me so I'm just gonna
be failing with my ear this whole show
but I'll try and power through this is
my flu game
oh you're good we we know what you're
doing we know you're fixing the ifb but
we want to know what's your pick for
this next play because we're trying to
get to the money today Sam
all right I'm gonna get you back here
Greg but we are taking the Niners uh at
home today
um against the Chiefs plus one
um I I really like this Niners team I've
said this last week when I took the
Falcons the only reason I was fading the
Niners is because they weren't healthy
they're getting healthy this week Bosa
back Williams back Jimmy Ward back this
team is loaded when healthy obviously
they have McCaffrey I'm not sure how
much of an impact he's gonna be in this
game but even as a Decoy for a few plays
I'm sure Shanahan will whip some stuff
up this bro or this Niners team ranks
higher than the Chiefs in dvoa for the
season which is really impressive
considering how many injuries San
Francisco's had to deal with this year
so they're getting healthy the Chiefs
defense is is really bad 28th
um it's a good matchup for Jimmy G to to
not blow the game so I like the Niners
today
I wanted you to keep talking Sam
honestly I didn't want to stop you I I
did not want to shut up I had to rush my
I had to rush my roast of the Chiefs
defense but uh it's very bad I'll just
say that because you were filling it up
you were filling it up uh for San
Francisco 49ers they are healthy Sam you
made a great point they're getting
healthy a lot of guys that were inactive
last week are back in the lineup this
week against those Chiefs I heard it's a
Revenge game for the Super Bowl a couple
years ago but we will see producer Ryan
did I say Joey both uh Nick Bosa uh
that's hand up there
it's all good bro we we know who you
meant we know who you meant Nick Bosa
the defensive end for the San Francisco
49ers but
producer Ryan you're in the chat talk to
me talk to Sam
how are the people feeling about the
first three plays
yeah I'm I'm
shocked that the people are as on board
with the commanders as they are uh this
is a team with a backup quarterback like
you said Greg I'm playing the Green Bay
Packers uh we've got W Bray saying take
Washington and the points so he likes
them on the money line and he likes the
points uh Benjamin hartright says
heinecke is a baller
I disagree uh Keenan
again are these really doesn't mean he's
really good quarterback that's fair that
does not mean he's really good
come on Keenan Fuller heinecke is really
good that's what a follow-up uh Larry
Loden saying uh Sam's losing a lot of
money today so I give you the good and
the bad I had to mix it in thank you
thank you
one more trigger away saying dogs are
barking today I see say I'm giving three
dogs
shout out to the dogs shout out to the
dogs barking today apparently Sam has
another dog coming up Sam we gave him
three dogs
are we giving them another
we are
um I I like Seattle today plus five
again I think we kind of we've got to
get our preconceived notions about what
these teams were before the season like
we all thought the Seahawks were going
to be horrendous the Seahawks team is
good this offense is really good fourth
overall offensively in dvoa Geno Smith
has been absolutely balling and the
Chargers just have not impressed me this
year at all I know everyone with last
week is roasting the Broncos and Russell
Wilson for everything they did in that
game but like it's sort of mass the
Chargers also didn't move the ball at
all late in that game and that game
probably would have been a tie if the
Broncos don't muff the punt so uh and
they've just a lot of one score games a
lot of close games so I think the
Seattle Seahawks keep this game close
five points is a lot they move the ball
really well your boy Kenneth Walker Greg
getting it done I like Seattle yeah
hey time told you guys about Kenneth
Walker I drafted him so I I feel really
good about that stash you know a little
draft and Stash from a fantasy team uh
he's out there balling but Sam you're a
big dvoa guy huh
I love it I like to I like to look at
the advance I don't care about you know
rush yards allowed per game because you
got to look at on a per play basis how
much are they running the ball that
matters
big dvoa guy big analytics guy Sam
Richmond Sam all right you gave us four
you gave us four we got two more to go
we're barking right now we are barking
because we have all dogs on the board uh
talk to us talk to me talk to the people
is the next one gonna be a dog as well
it's not I'm I'm reversing of course
here uh we are taking the Dolphins minus
seven points to get today against the
Pittsburgh Steelers I want everyone to
go back like three weeks in what we
thought of this Dolphins team and this
Dolphins offense before that to a
catastrophic injury like they were
rolling and that team was very very good
and obviously two is back today
um I hope for his sake beyond my bet
Beyond football that he's he's fully
healthy but that team is really good and
I know the Steelers won last week but I
think that is more of a product to do
with Tom Brady being old and not good
um no but that box team is just a mess
um so I I don't trust Kenny Pickett I
like this Dolphins team at this point uh
I just don't see the Steelers being able
to put enough points and I think the
Dolphins and The Playmakers involved and
cover the seven here
there it is my man Sam says the Dolphins
are bouncing back I like the dolphin Sam
they got the coach from the San
Francisco 49er Street Mike McDaniels
he's out there he's out there he's out
there coaching he's out there coaching
he lost his quarterback lost his backup
quarterback still got his team out there
being very very competitive uh so I like
that play Sam I like that one a lot
that's five that is five we got one more
to go
Sam talk to me talk to the people
what are we doing with this last one I'm
I'm sorry New York New York is really
going to hate me today because I'm going
against them in both games but I'm
taking the Jags minus three uh I know
everyone looked at this game it was like
the Jags are two and four the Giants are
five and one how are the Jacks favored
again I think like my lesson to anyone
who's betting on sports would be stop
looking just at results and win records
and looked at the advanced metrics of
who is actually a good team and who's
not and I'm sorry I just I still don't
believe in this Giants team the Jags are
the better team uh their defense is very
good their pass rush is very good which
is going to be really trouble for Daniel
Jones the giant Stevens ranks bottom and
every defensive category they're like
30th overall in TeamViewer this team is
just not that great kudos to them for
for winning for being five and one but
uh I think the Jags humble them a bit
today
Sam's fade in New York today he's fading
New York today uh
I like that pick I like that minus three
pick with the Jaguars let's bring back
in producer Ryan because I want to know
if the peoples feel like how I'm feeling
if they're disagreeing if they're
sending Good Vibes bat Vibes what's
going on in the chat man
uh yeah I'm back in the chat and Kenan
Fuller is coming after me for the Taylor
heineckees is really good uh chat
comment he said I said in comparison to
backup QBs but of course you ignore that
comment to fit your narrative
I have an agenda and I'm always trying
to protect it and everyone knows you
struggle with actually reading what the
commenters say right yeah good thank you
good call out thanks Sam made the joke
before the show but I'm glad you decided
to fit it in here
yeah yeah good one maybe make it a third
time later on uh Andy Pandy says
Chargers are so bad so he's with you
there on the Seahawks 82 percent of the
public is on uh is with you on the
Seahawks just a nice little stat there
uh AP 23 says big blue gets it done
today
uh W Bray says New York's averaging six
yards per play but the defense gives up
five per play not substantial red snake
Giants are trash jets are trash uh
clearly not a New Yorker good take
um good team yeah
rsjs like the Giants fans think this
team is going like 13-4 with like Daniel
Jones in a poverty defense like they're
not that good I'm sorry yeah somebody
who uh who lives in New York they do
they think they're going 16-1 and
they're winning I think they're going to
the Super Bowl well they also thought
the Yankees were going to beat the
Astros and Mattress mackers so yeah
that's sad now you want to talk about
baseball this week interesting how did
the Padres do last night I know I don't
want to talk about baseball I just like
trolley New York
uh last one rsj says Miami is now four
and a half I don't know if that's true
uh just a disclaimer I I never know if
the chat is trolling near was two a
ruled out or something
I can see the boys I'll double check and
I'll come back
okay right take a peek out of your room
and then come back uh so we can see the
board literally outside our Las Vegas uh
rooms here let's move on though let's
move on
um you guys know what time it is every
show we got the anytime touchdown score
and you guys know what we do here I'm
gonna boost it anytime touchdown score
for you guys Ryan pull up those odds and
talk to the people
all right
so here we go Derrick Henry who some are
saying is back uh minus 170 is the most
bet anytime TD scorer today uh Travis
Kelsey against Greg's Niners uh Austin
Eckler who has just been a touchdown
machine as of late uh in there in the
middle at minus 190 and here's where I
think things get interesting the Tampa
Bay Buccaneers who have struggled to
score as of late uh have struggled to
beat anyone as of late have two
touchdown scorers in this top eight
Leonard fournette at minus 150 and Mike
Evans at plus money plus 105 to round
things out here uh so there's definitely
value to be had here uh whether or not
the Bucks score today is a different
story uh but these are the most bet
anytime TD props make sure you drop your
uh lock in the chat
um we'll we'll grade it there it is
we'll try it I don't mean to interrupts
but are you guys running like a
practical joke on me about the Dolphins
a producer came in my ear and said the
Dolphins were minus three I'm on
DraftKings right now they're mine is
seven and a half they're not mine
you guys are live trying to get in my
head third seven and a half Point
favorites hey Sam stay focused stay
focused on the goal we you know like
what what how are they drop Four Points
no just collusion against me
stay focused Sam hey Ryan uh talk to me
what are the people talking about in the
chat who are they liking for any time
touchdown scorer so Benjamin hartright
says and you'll like this Greg uh CMC
gets a TD today uh we'll see how much he
actually plays uh King Ocho Eckler is a
lock uh bsk says take Isaiah Pacheco
anytime TD today boys
um a lot of people on the Niners and the
Chiefs chips don't find the end zone
today I'm just kidding
uh mad Dodger Joe Mixon anytime TD uh
Hey Kibby says Derrick Henry anytime TD
so we're taking the minus Ryan what was
that minus 170.
yeah minus 170 Ryan let's make a
decision bro let's let's make a decision
love the takes in the comments but it's
it's time to get to the money it's time
to get to the nitty-gritty so here
here's where I stand the Cults are a
poverty poverty team and we have a lot
of comments in here who are now backing
the Derrick Henry anytime TD take so
should we make magic happen here Greg
should we lock it in Sam are you riding
I'm with it I'm with it I ride with the
people everyone knows I'm a man of
people
hey there it is we we we're locking it
in I'm gonna do my magic now I'm gonna
do my magic Ryan Ryan's in the chat the
people have spoken they said Derrick
Henry Sam likes it I like it so you guys
see that minus set 170 on your screen
watch this goof we just boosted it up it
went from minus 170 to minus 110 uh only
us we're doing that with our friends
over at DraftKings before we go though
before we go
who are you riding with to score a
touchdown today Sam
I'm just gonna take Jalen waddle because
I feel like anytime TD is a little bit
of crap shoot and Jaylen waddle has the
absolute best touchdown celebration with
the waddle um of anyone in the league
it's better than the group I was going
to tell you
I was going to tell you you got to do it
for us bro
yeah if it hits you guys
I'll do it I'll do it I'll do it outside
hey there it is uh I'm rocking with Debo
though I think Christian McCaffrey is
going to play Big decoy today that's
going to open up the field for my man
Debo in the red zone so I'm rocking with
Debo against those Kansas City chief it
is a Redemption game for the 49ers in
that Super Bowl loss if you want to
combine my pick Sam's pick and your pick
DraftKings will boost it by 25 check out
our social accounts for more details on
the BR betting Pay Dirt parlay all right
guys
you guys know we just talked about
Christian McCaffrey I'm excited I'm
literally like I'm so excited I'm still
excited we posted a video on our socials
of me being excited and going to go bet
the 49ers like literally minutes after
the trade and uh I'm still confident I'm
still feeling that way I still think
that my 49ers are Super Bowl contenders
but I I really feel like this just took
the 49ers over top we got a running back
who's not only a running back he's
another slot receiver he's another wide
receiver he's a running back shoot he
can even throw the ball like my man
Christian McCaffrey is very very very uh
diverse when it comes to the football
field and what he can do and he's also
returning back to the Bay Area say I'm I
I I I know you're a college football guy
but yeah he's returning back to the Bay
Area he's a Stanford Stanford grad and
uh so he's coming home I honestly I
think he's coming home
you guys tell us how you guys feel about
the Christian McCaffrey trade getting
those comments use those VR apps social
fingers and let us know how you guys are
feeling about the Niners uh trading for
Christian McCaffrey
I think that this puts them in Super
Bowl contention I I actually let me
rephrase that I already thought that
they were Super Bowl contenders but I
think that this one really really puts
them up there with the big boys by
Landing another playmaker like Christian
McCaffrey
um
Sam Ryan your takes how are you guys
feeling about Christian McCaffrey going
to the 49ers I'm I'm with you like I
really like this Niners team as a
contender even before the trade
um I think we'll see in the long term if
they gave up too many picks but if
you're just talking about this year and
the Futures it obviously makes them
better but just especially with how weak
the NFC is like they're who are the good
teams in the NFC Niners Eagles
Cowboys kind of with that back it's a
yeah I don't believe in Kirk Cousins but
it's pretty bad so any team who is
fairly good uh is going to be a
contender and I think the Niners are in
that upper tier and and I do think 16-1
is a really good number for them
especially again the division is bad too
the Rams are poverty the Cardinals stink
Seahawks are actually decent but they're
not going to mess with the Niners to win
that division so
um I like it Craig
Niners only go as far as gvg will take
them but hopefully getting another
playmaker will get the balls out of
Jimmy G hands uh
because yeah we you we all know how I
feel about the Ryan talk to us see what
talk to me what the people say uh how we
feeling about Chris McCaffrey
um yeah uh Jang says cmc's trash uh M
Kent saying he's gonna get hurt in three
weeks uh old dirt says CMC is good until
he's hurt
it's tough I mean he does have an injury
history he is only 25.
um so if he could stay healthy obviously
we know what he can do uh
arcadius says Jimmy will fold the Niners
I don't know if you I feel like you
agree with that Greg
um yeah and then red snake says gave up
way too much for a guy who lives on the
IR
okay
I I gotta talk about that
if we go back and watch Christian
McCaffrey playing for the Carolina
Panthers he was the Bell count he was
their their horse they were feeding
Christian McCaffrey like he was getting
so many touches so many fantasy points
everybody was talking about it but
that's because they were literally
feeding him the ball now he's going to a
team that we don't necessarily need to
feed Christian McCaffrey the ball we
have other Playmakers and then we I mean
the 49ers have other playmakers that
needs the ball in their hands so
Christian McCaffrey probably aren't
going to see the touches the numbers of
touches that he was seeing for the
Carolina Packers I mean Panthers I'm
sorry Carolina Panthers which means you
know he might not be injured as much you
know so I'm sending the Good Vibes into
the atmosphere sending the Good Vibes in
there and also the Niners like to have a
running back by committee Jeff Wilson
have been bawling and I highly doubt I
highly doubt the Niners are just gonna
like throw him to the side because
Christian McCaffrey came into the fold
no it's it's a it's a committee out
there in San Francisco that's running
the ball Christopher McCaffrey I think
he'll be all right I think he'll be all
right uh
let's let's grade some picks let's grade
some pics Ryan get in the comments
what are they talking about
um and we're just gonna grade some of
their picks because they're on our picks
Sam they they were talking about us they
were giving us bad vibes they were you
know critiquing our plays so it's time
to reverse the roles you guys want to be
mentioned on the show get in the
comments right now start typing because
my man Ryan's going to say your play and
it's time for me and Sam to talk our
smack just kidding we're gonna say Good
Vibes though we got uh Kevin Morgan in
the chat Thanking us for the free room
at Foxwoods uh so glad people were able
to to enjoy that in the DraftKings
sports book there
um Anthony Pittman also sang 49ers 49ers
will go as far as Bosa will take them
I'm just going to give that an F minus I
don't think I've ever discarded
uh but we'll get we'll we'll start uh
start giving some bets here so Eddie MC
says I like the Ravens minus six and a
half today against the Cleveland Browns
what do you guys think
I love the Ravens I'm a I'm a big Ravens
guy I they should be 6-0 as someone who
is the Ravens to win the Super Bowl this
team should be 6-0 well look at their
losses like they dominated the Giants
and then Lamar melted down
we're about 20 to 30 on the bills we're
killing the Dolphins they should be five
and one six and oh they're really good
the Browns are a mess I'm losing my
voice in Vegas
um so maybe I'll stop but I do like
Baltimore today
the Browns are oh and three covering the
spread in their last three games
I think that train continues so I I I'll
give I'll give this guy C plus B minus
okay
tough grader uh who's next says Detroit
Lions money line against the Dallas
Cowboys today in Dallas they're they're
seven point underdogs
wow I don't like it I haven't been a big
lions guy all year I think they're just
inflated because people think Dan
Campbell is a good personality
um I I like these Cowboys team he has a
good personality but like it's not we
don't bet guys with that
you're a Cowboys fan what are you doing
because of that okay no no but I don't I
don't know Dan Campbell slander I'm not
accepting Dax back right yeah his deck
is very black
it's gonna be an interesting game it's
going to be a really really interesting
game
um
I don't know about the money line but I
like to spread with the with the with
the Lions
Dax coming back Jerry Jones been talking
about quarterback controversy out there
you know so I feel like there's going to
be pressure on that today and is he
going to deliver under the pressure
we'll see he never usually does uh I
will say the most bet the most bad
player prop on DraftKings today is Dak
Prescott over one and a half passing
touchdowns at minus uh it was minus 155
it's now minus 140.
so
that's a big fade spot for me there
um but yeah all right let's get back
into the chat how do you hate your teams
I don't understand it uh because my
teams hate me they all they do is hurt
me I only know heartbreak
um
Braden Regan says Chicago Bears plus
eight and a half
plus seven and a half I'm sorry
I think that's going to be as of now I
think that's gonna be like the first
Prime Time game I I sit out because the
Bears are the Bears are so bad
um that's a lot of points it's it's a
lot of points
um so I I do not have a great feel on
that game and the Patriots have been
super impressive but it does it feels
like a high line but I also can't trust
the Bears to do anything
yeah same I feel the same way Sam it's a
high line
we are talking about the Bears and on
the other side there's Bill Belichick so
uh
Line's tricky It's Tricky
I would like to see because uh it's an
incomplete grade because I that's a stay
away from me let's stay away from me but
uh we'll see long time before game time
for me to change my mind
that's true
uh all right trouble since 1983. uh I'm
Gonna Want A Story I mean what happened
in 1983 but uh Atlanta plus six and a
half
what's that probably born in 1983 if you
want to just do some some basic
deduction
oh okay yeah we'll see we'll see
Troublesome you dropped the story we'll
see yeah right tell us what happened in
1983 uh but Atlanta Falcons plus six and
a half against the Cincinnati Bengals
today that's his play
a not only reason I say that the Falcons
been covered bro they're they're like
against the spread
gurus this year they've been covering
yeah if yeah they actually have covered
every game yeah and uh
I think that Trend continues so I like
yeah that one I've been betting on the
Falcons a lot this one was a stay away
for me
um I don't know it this does set up as a
good spot for the Bengals uh and I don't
know I'm I'm a little wary of of the
Falcons can they keep doing this with
having Mariota throw 12 times a game so
we'll see
yeah
because uh I do the Roger Goodell uh
Marcus Mariota when he announces draft
pick so I'm sorry if I slipped up on air
very impressive I was impressed real
ones will get that sound real ones we'll
definitely get that
Google Roger Goodell Marcus Mariota
that's funny
so well Sam moves to 28-14 on this show
trouble since 1983 says yes born in 83.
so let's go love that love that congrats
there bit huge for you huge for you
maybe your only win today who knows
we'll see uh G-Man says Panthers plus 13
and a half against the Tampa Bay
Buccaneers
that that's like a c for me because
again like the Panthers are so bad but
so are the Bucks like the Bucks are just
not good I'm I'm so out in the bucks but
I it's hard for me to trust a team that
is completely tanking like Carolina is
um they want Bryce young or CJ Stroud uh
or will Henderson no they'll take
quarterback
um but it's hard for me to trust them
there this this does feel like a week
where Brady gets right but
minus 13 points in the NFL with a team
that's been this bad I can't take it so
full stay away
yeah earlier in the week I saw it at -11
and I like the Bucks
sharp action we all know line moved
uh so at the line it is now
maybe buy down a little bit but I do
think Brady bounces back this week
okay uh we're gonna do one more here
Anthony Pittman this is a two leg parlay
Colts money line 49ers money line what
do you guys think
love the Niners play I like the Niners
funny line I I don't know I'm I have a
Colts AFC South future so this is a very
very big game for me I will say this the
Colts actually did play for the first
time all season a good football game
last week
um so that's a little encouraging but
they've been so bad all season so it's
kind of one of those things like for me
I want if they can do it again this week
if the Colts can put together another
good performance then I'm like all right
maybe this team will start to resemble
the team we thought they'd be at the
start of the year but it's really hard
for me to trust it because they've been
so atrocious outside of last week
Titans are at home too they they play
better at home than on the road uh so I
I don't know if I can get behind that
one but I can get behind the first play
so I'll give it I'll give a c plus
because you know first play I like
second play
seasons
category hey hey if anybody knows that
it's me C's definitely do get degrees
look at me I mean I'm here
thank you hey Ryan Sam it's been fun man
it's been fun hey we gotta go actually
get ready to prepare for this Raider
game Ryan
yes sir Sam has to prepare for that that
that flight back home and and possibly
watching watching that that later game
on the plane uh the game that he said he
has no interest in but we'll see we'll
see he probably he might bet it he might
bet it before he takes a long day it's a
long day it's a long long long day it's
a lot of money to be made hey it's been
fun guys my name is Greg Iber for Sam
Richmond and producer Ryan we
are out peace
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]